now that we've described the
instantaneous velocity of an object we'd
now like to describe what it's
acceleration is velocity and
acceleration are complicated things one
of the reasons why acceleration is such
an abstract quantity is for example if I
take this marker that's in my hand and I
throw it up in the air and I catch it
you can see with your eye velocity you
can see the speed you have a sense for
it you can see it changed its direction
so velocity is something that is a human
being with our eye as a mechanism for
determining motion velocity is a very
basic concept but acceleration is a much
harder concept for instance when I take
that same object and I drop that as it
falls down its velocity is increasing
and so we say it has an acceleration but
is that acceleration a function of time
or is it constant in time is it varying
in times at a polynomial is it a
constant those are much harder to see
again let's drop this object so when I
drop that object and I catch it down
here our eye does not tell us
intuitively anything about the
mathematical nature of that acceleration
and that's why acceleration is a much
more abstract quantity in fact a great
question is the following when I throw
this object up in the air let's focus at
its highest point so I throw it in the
air
and it comes down when the object was at
its highest point was its velocity zero
was it its acceleration zero or nonzero
a hint to this question is in Newton's
second law F equals MA if there's a
force acting on this object there must
be an acceleration and that forces the
gravitational force and when this object
was at the top of its motion I didn't
turn the earth off so there's still a
gravitational force and so for an object
in freefall
now freefall just as under the which
means under the influence of the
gravitational force
we can conclude from Newton's second law
that the gravitational force MA
so this gravitational force is nonzero
and so therefore the acceleration is
also nonzero so once again as I throw
this object up in the air nobody turned
gravity off we're not in empty space and
near the surface of the earth the
gravitational force is not zero the
acceleration is not zero so throughout
this motion this object is accelerating
I choose this example to show you that
acceleration is a very abstract concept
and now our goal is to figure out how to
mathematically define acceleration in
terms of our velocity